hello everyone and welcome back to the
clutch just international we are
continuing with the match Lebanon versus
Alexander Grisha
and it is one of the games that was most
requested so I do hope you enjoy it it's
quite the treat eleven witted the white
pieces opened the width efore and this
is a game 12 of their match so the final
game of the match we might cover some
others I still haven't had a chance to
go through all of them but if if you
know of of a good game do use hashtag
suggestion and I will go through your
suggestions and Grisha replies with c5
he goes for the Sicilian defense we have
90 f3 d6 and now Knight to c3 so waiting
for a moment before striking in the
center Knight to f6 and only now d4 so C
captures with Queen captures on d4
usually Knight captures on d4 is played
but here Levin has something very
unusual prepared with Knight to c6 and
now Bishop to b5 is almost exclusively
played here however other moves are have
been seen like Queen d3 Queen to d1
Quincy for Quinta a4 basically keeping
to the white squares however here 11
goes for Queen to e3 and it is a new
move so already as of move six we have a
completely new game now what's the idea
behind the move well 11 will show us
here however if you're up early if your
opponent gives you an opportunity to
play d5 in the Sicilian you should
pretty much almost always do it and here
a good issue goes for it so d5 and the
point is if you just trade everything
captures captures captures and captures
black should have a very nice game the
queen is nicely developed in the center
there is no night to kick away the Queen
so it it is possible to go for this
however after this d5 move we have
Bishop to b5 so not allowing black such
nice development and now Knight captures
on e4 and before recapturing Knight the
d4 preparing to capture on c6 so now the
point is if you play something like
Knight captures on c3 of course white
will first capture on c6 attack blacks
Queen black doesn't really have any good
two jumps with the night so be capture
Censorship CalPERS and c6 check will win
the exchange after
Bishop to Bishop to d7 is played so
after this night 34 move a Grecian first
goes for Bishop to d7 and now Knight
captures on e4
with D captures on e4 and now first
Bishop characters on c6
now you could recapture with the bishop
however then white captures the bishop
and you will again ruin your pawn
structure
so here B captures and only now Queen
captures on e4 and now White's white is
definitely up in development black will
need a few more moves to get his King to
safety on the other hand black does have
the bishop pair so if black can just
continue developing get the King to
safety utilize the bishop pair then
black should be more than okay so Queen
to a5 check with Bishop to d2 11 says
thank you for helping me develop and now
Queen to d5 immediately offering a queen
trade as it's very dangerous for the
black king still being in the center of
the board and here 11 declines Queen
back to e3 really really liking that EE
3 squared this game and now you have to
decide that do you want to develop with
let's say I move like 'if I've preparing
to develop leadership castle and so on
let's say Knight b3 Bishop to e7
but now white castles Queen side and you
don't really have time for this because
of Bishop the c3 will open up a
discovery to the Queen and you will go
after the e5 pawn so here black would
have to play f6 and then the game
continues it is playable of course but
our Grecian issue doesn't think that
this is the way to go instead he goes
for c5 kicks the night away this way
Knight to e2 and now comes east six now
he will develop the bishop and castle
the King to safety but now Bishop the c3
Levin says oh no you don't if you
develop the Bishop then I'm just gonna
grab the g7 pawn so Bishop the c6 first
saying that okay you're not castling
queenside and you're definitely not
castling queenside adieu to Queen
captures and g2 checkmate
so 11 first goes f3 now it is possible
to Castle kingside sense idea
three-point prevents checkmate and now
the shop dub east 7 Grisha offers the g7
pawn and now the problem with capturing
the pawn is that well for one it's super
complicated and you don't want to waste
too much time it
rapid game for example rook g8 and then
you have to decide you remove the bishop
and then you lose the G to pawn or you
play some like rook d1 attack the Queen
and after Queen c4 Queen h6 and you get
this super complicated game Queen
captures and c2 prevents white from
castling as you would lose the night
here and it's just really really really
difficult position even the ideas like
Rudy - with a threefold repetition or
possible check Rudy one here back check
and and so on so we might even see this
however now LaVon is not interested in
this he goes Knights the f4 puts
pressure on the Queen and Queen to f5
now going for the for the c2 pond and
here h4 not allowing a Bishop to g5 to
go after the knight and also preventing
g5 doesn't allow this attack on the
night so Bishop to d6 puts a double
attack on the knight now and only now a
knight back the e2 giving the district
the opportunity to grab that seat upon
so Queen captures and c2 and now rook to
d1 attacks the bishop on d6 with Bishop
to e7 and now Knight back to Knight back
to f4 you don't want it to be a target
here if the Queen and the king move and
it's also a very strong piece on f4 so
grief should finally castles and 11 also
just castles so we have castles King
side and here you have to decide whether
you want to capture this pawn and allow
Queen captures and c5 for example
captures captures and then let's say you
bring the roof to help out with the
defense of the bishop and the black
should definitely have a good game here
not not much to worry about
however Ganesha played rook F to d8
right away so now you obviously need to
deal with the threat of rook captures
rook as now the rook is attacked twice
so you could trade here now or maybe
there is a better idea maybe there is a
move that is so good that you should
even pause the video and try to find it
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
and find the entire continuation
congratulations and being a spectacular
player and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's
rook to c1 this
vallevan plate and it's really an
amazing move point is you have to go
back to a four if you go Queen to f5
then g4 traps the Queen
you don't actually lose the Queen since
you do have rook to de you could play
this and give up the rook instead but
still I mean the game is just lost after
Knight captures you can now move the
Queen but still you're down a whole rook
so Queen to f5 would have been a
terrible blunder so Grisha of course
went Queen to a4 but now comes 11th main
idea which you couldn't play before
because of the threat rook captures and
d1 but now that the rook isn't on d1 the
real threat shows itself Knight captures
on e6 and it's just it's just a terrible
move for black face because you can't
really ignore the night there's also a
double attack on the g7 point now and
you could try some ideas like rook to d5
with the idea that let's say maybe Queen
can capture here you can bring the rook
in and maybe do some damage here however
then just 97 and there's a nice fork
you're gonna win one of the rooks so
it's it's a position where black really
doesn't have a good move to play also
just you could just capture the rook
here so it's really really just a tough
position so what you could do is let's
say rook d5 the move we mentioned and
allow this fork you could try Queen
captures on h4
and give up the exchange this way so
this is also possible one thing you
cannot do is accept this since it loses
the game terribly but this is exactly
what the Grisha who did point is Queen
captures any sex with check which is
what Levin played and now the problem is
you could defend the bishop with King to
f8 or you could try giving up the bishop
but the problem is none of this works
because if King to h8 you just go Bishop
captures and g7 and now there is nothing
black can do you have to capture it
Queen captures on e7 with check and now
it doesn't really matter where the Queen
of where the King goes at some point the
Queen will grab hold of this diagonal
and the rook will be able to come to c4
that's the idea so for example King to
g8 or to h8 doesn't really matter
you're gonna go Queen f6 to e6 first so
here Queen to ecigs check into a trade
and now just work the c-4 is it's game
over for black because whatever you do
doesn't really matter you could move the
Queen capture the pawn just Queen f6
check in g8 and the rook to g4 will be
checkmate so this is the threat so after
Queen to e6 check of course Grisha who
did not go here he defended his Bishop
but now there's a different idea that
wins so feel free to pause the video and
win the game for Levin while I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on paying attention as it's the exact
same idea that works and for those of
you who just won't enjoy the show it's
Bishop characters and g7 so it's the
same as if the king was on h8 only now
he's on f8 so if you capture we go into
the same line and if Quinta e8 then just
Roxy t1 and there's not much you can do
to defend against this share mighty
fruit d7 Queen g8 is checkmate the
bishop cannot defend it is pinned and if
you don't defend with the rogue if you
let's say you go Queen captures on h4
then Bishop to f6 wins because of course
there's nothing to do Queen captures
Queen captures and the bishop still
cannot recapture so of course completely
winning for white so a Greek had to
capture the bishop but now we go into
the same line as we've already shown so
not much suspense here Queen captures on
e7 which check was played King g8 Queen
the e6 check grabbing hold of the C 4
square king to a trade and now of course
rook the c4 and it was in this position
that Alexander very shook resigned the
game and with it the D match as it is 11
Aragon who who proceeds to the
semifinals to face Magnus Carlsen so
here like we already mentioned you
resign because after you move the Queen
let's say wherever whatever you do Queen
f6 checking do it and rook to g4 will be
checkmate or if you don't want to do
this you could try and give up the Queen
however it's not not much to go with as
after characters captures you only have
a bishop and the rook for a queen which
is not all that impressive so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it so me
you suggested it yesterday as soon as it
was played so I knew it was it was a
good one even before seeing it but after
I've seen it you know thank you for
suggesting it yeah I would like to thank
guna Lipka Shubham stone Avani my kennel
king your studio online and chad piper
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the clutch chest international checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent the rest of your day